صنع رئيس الوزراء نفتالي بينيت
التاريخ هنا عندما التقى
لأول مرة لرئيس وزراء
إسرائيلي بأي مسؤول إماراتي هنا على
الأراضي الإماراتية التقى به لمدة أربع ساعات
أي أطول بساعتين مما كان
مقررًا مع ولي عهد أبوظبي
محمد بن زايد
ثم  تركت هذه الرسالة
ورائي ، لقد أنهيت زيارة جيدة هنا
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، وأود أن
أشكر صاحب السمو محمد بن زايد
على كرم الضيافة
خلال هذه الزيارة
طوال اليوم ، أجرينا
محادثات هادفة ومتعمقة ومباشرة
حول بلدينا  حول المنطقة
وحول اقتصادنا وتقنيتنا
وما يمكننا القيام به معًا ،
سأعود إلى إسرائيل وأنا
متفائل جدًا بأن هذه العلاقة
يمكن أن تكون مثالًا
على كيفية صنع السلام هنا في
الشرق الأوسط الآن ، ما هو ملحوظ في
هذه الرسالة هو ذلك  لا يوجد
ذكر لإيران ولا للفلسطينيين في الواقع
العددان من الحروف الحمراء لليوم الذي
يتصدران القائمة على الرغم من حقيقة أن إيران
مع  الإماراتيون يتعارضون بشدة
مع الإسرائيليين
وحتى مع الولايات المتحدة في رأيهم
أنه لم يعد من المجدي
ممارسة أي ضغط جاد على الإيرانيين الذين
يحاولون حملهم على العودة إلى
الاتفاق النووي الذي
مزقه دونالد ترامب فعليًا  أه كانت صفقة
تهدف إلى تقليص قدرتها على
إنتاج سلاح نووي الآن كانت
هناك جهود في ظل
إدارة بايد لإحياء
تلك الاتفاقية التي انسحب الإيرانيون مؤخرًا
من الأمريكيين
أرادوا عقوبات أكبر
دلت على ذلك وكان الإماراتيون
سريعون للغاية  يقولون إنهم ليسوا
مهتمين بفرض أي عقوبات أخرى
بالفعل على طهران
أنهم كانوا يخططون لبناء مزرعة كبيرة للطاقة الشمسية
في إيران ، لقد أرسلوا
وفودًا دبلوماسية رفيعة المستوى
وبالطبع فإن الإسرائيليين في
الخلفية لديهم  يهددون
بعمل عسكري إذا لم يكن هناك
حل دبلوماسي لإنهاء برنامج إيران
النووي المزعوم ولكن في  في الوقت نفسه ، كان
هذا أيضًا انتصارًا لنفتالي
بينيت ، فقد كان سلفه هو الذي
تفاوض بشكل فعال على ما
يسمى باتفاقات إبراهيم التي
طبيعت العلاقة
بين الإمارات العربية المتحدة
والعديد من الدول العربية الأخرى وإسرائيل
بقيادة الإمارات التي كانت مشهورة.
اختراق في الدبلوماسية في ظل سنوات عديدة
من العزلة ، هذان البلدان
لم يخضعا أبدًا حربًا معًا ضد
بعضهما البعض ، لكن من المؤكد
أنهما كانا فاترين للغاية ، وكان من المستحيل
حتى قبل 15 شهرًا بالنسبة
لمواطن إسرائيلي أن تطأ قدمه هنا الآن هناك
حوالي سبع رحلات جوية و  إلى الوراء وإلى
الأمام بين إسرائيل ودبي ،
يتم التخطيط للعديد من العمليات السياحية الأخرى
وما قاله الجانبان
من هذا الاجتماع هو أنهما كانا
يأملان في تعميق العلاقة الاقتصادية
التي تبلغ قيمتها بالفعل حوالي 600
مليون دولار سنويًا وقبل كل شيء
دعوة مقدمة من  رئيس
الوزراء الإسرائيلي لولي عهد أبو ظبي
لزيارتها
في بعض المستقبل  يوم صنع إسرائيل
وتم قبوله
سام كيلي سي إن في أبو ظبي